the worst thing I could think of is you
spill it and your kitchen looks like a
murder scene I'm in the dawn gloves
because we're working with blood gets
under your fingernails it may seem like
an unlikely ingredient in modern cuisine
but blood is popping up on menus across
the country it's no different than
utilizing any offcut of the animal all
the greatest cuisines in the world are
definitely sprung out of the need to
utilize everything this is corn masa we
dehydrated it for the purpose of
rehydrating it with pig's blood why
would you use blood and not water for us
it's just about the flavor what the
taste like when it's raw it's actually
not pleasant at all when you cook it if
you love great chicken liver if you love
great calves liver it's a better version
of that along with flavor and
rehydration blood can also act as a
thickener and color dye
it's a very polarizing ingredient it's
either there's no way in hell I'm
ordering that or oh man awesome should I
file of course you should you should try
everything
you should try every exciting new
confrontational culinary thing that
comes across your path it's still very
much unfortunately a taboo ingredient I
find the best way to get someone to try
something is to craft it into a small
beautiful bite
you